[MUSIC]
Try to go back in time and
imagine yourself as a baby.
I'm not going to ask you to start
crying or crawling around the room.
But try to think of
the major learnings you had.
Perhaps it was learning how to walk,
or how to hold an object by yourself.
Maybe it was learing how not
to hit your baby friends.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or even how to say your first words.
But let me ask you, by a show of hands,
how many of you were taught how to see?
No one, right?
You shouldn't blame your parents for that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My point here is that human sight is
usually taken for granted.
Unless you lose it for some reason, or
unless you were born with an eye
impairment, which was my case.
To your friendly eyes, it might seem
that I don't have any problem, but
I was born blind from my left eye and
I have low vision in my right one.
So I'd like to welcome you to my world.
That's probably a very good
approximation of how I see things.
In this case, this is not a thing, but
actually the love of my
life on our wedding day.
But the fact is that since I was a kid,
I had to understand how
to go through that blur.
I had to learn how to see.
Now you might be asking,
what learning how to see looks like?
What is seeing?
Well, biology has an explanation for us.
It says that it's all about light.
Light that goes through a series of
very delicate structures in our eye,
like the cornea or the pupil,
until it finally reaches our retina.
A photo sensitive tissue that transforms
light into electrical signals.
Those electrical signals
then are possessed and
travel from our eye to our brain.
So in fact, our eyes just collect visual
information, but we see with our brain.
According to science,
vision is an activity
90% mental and only 10% physical.
So when I look back into my struggles,
I see now that biology is indeed right.
And the act of seeing is much more in
here, and maybe in here, than in here.
I truly believe that real sight
is based on three main attitudes,
completely unrelated to
our physical condition.
And I hope to share them with you today,
through some of the lessons
that I had in my life.
My first lesson came pretty early,
at the age of four.
Trying to help me be part in
the world in a different way,
my parents decided to put
me in a music school.
And before even learning
how to read words,
by transforming those little black
blurry stains into music notes,
I was able to see a brand
new world through sound.
But seeing that world
required a lot of effort,
a lot of practice and a lot of dedication.
So I learned that seeing is actually about
the level of depth you put in
everything you do in your life.
My second lesson came some
years later than that.
I was 17 years old, I was very shy.
Probably facing a lot of the same
challenges you've all faced at that age.
But I had this crazy idea of
auditioning to a theater company.
But crazier than me were the ones who
accepted an actor who could barely see
the to the other side of the stage.
But at that same stage,
with a bunch of light in my face,
I learned that seeing is
much more about perspective.
By looking to the world through the eyes
of many, many different characters,
I learned how different people are, and
yet, how similar we are to each other.
My third and
final lesson came more recently.
I've always been passionate
about photography.
Maybe because images were always
a bit mysterious and blurred to me,
I couldn't see them well.
But I never thoughy I would be able
to use that professional camera to
take professional photographs.
Well recently I met a photographer,
and he told me, have you ever noticed
that you only need one eye to look
through the view finder of a camera?
Indeed, he's right.
So this picture you're seeing here, was
taken by a photographer with just one eye.
You're looking at him right now.
So through my photographs,
I also learned that
vision is much more about
focusing in your dreams.
Focusing in what matters most to you,
and why.
>> I truly believe that all of those
lessons should be taught to us together
with that biology class I just
showed you some slides ago.
And I'm sure that you all have already
experienced at least one moment in your
lives where you didn't use even
those 10% to actually see the world.
Don't you remember that very first kiss
when you almost automatically
closed your eyes?
I'm sure you were very,
very focused at that moment.
>> [LAUGH]
>> How about the dozens of times your
friends asked you to close your eyes,
just to hit you with a surprise?
From a brand new perspective.
Not to mention,
watching a concert where your favorite
rock star closes his eyes
at the peak of the song.
I'm sure he was seeing a lot
of stuff in that moment, and
experiencing the deepest emotions.
Hellen Keller was an American educator and
an activist for the blind the deaf people.
She was blind actually.
And she once said, what I'm looking for
is not out there, it's in me.
So I'd like to invite you to step into my
world, even if you have perfect sight.
So the next time you face a challenge,
or a hard decision, or
even a simple pleasure in life, try not to
look at it only with your eyes wide open.
Close them, and open up your brain.
So you can unlock a different kind of
vision, one that goes beyond that blur.
And how to be more focused, broaden our
perspectives, and look deeper inside.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]